okay my Instagram account has had some
interesting things on it I'm on
instagram at david pakman first picture
is from this is post women's march in
Boston over the weekend I talked about
this pad I went to the woman's March a
lot of interesting signs that were left
over at the Boston Common which I took a
picture of it was high energy I would
say to take a vocabulary phrase out of
Crump's playbook it was very very high
energy I did my critique of it yesterday
I won't rehash it now but it was really
interesting to see just a sheer number
of people i think 25,000 were expected
in something like 125 or 150 showed up
and you can spend a long time looking at
those signs to there's some gems their
facts matter we are the mandate science
is real yell of a science is real
related to something Elizabeth Warren
said which is I know this is
controversial I'm paraphrasing but she
said something like I know it's
controversial in some circles to say
this but we believe in science and of
course it's sort of in a way it's weird
because science doesn't depend on belief
which is one of the most it's sort of
like an oxymoron in a way to say we
believe in science because science is
science regardless of what one believes
that's why we call it science but yes
very very interesting to see the sign
also on today's show we will be having
part one of my interview with white
nationalist alt right leader Richard
Spencer and yesterday I sent out a
behind-the-scenes picture we did this
yesterday this is my view during an
interview and you see the screen I see
the show on this is like those Russian
matryoshka dolls where it's like
successive layers this is a picture of
me watching the screen on which I see
the show and you can see Richard Spencer
there and and you can see me this is
before the interview you see that shiner
that black eye on Richard Spencer's face
from when he was punched at the Trump
inauguration and above that on the
little screen that you see sort of like
my notes although i don't have my notes
for the interview pulled up here people
liking pat the behind-the-scenes picture
here of the interview yeah and I'm
hoping they're going to like the
interview to it was certainly a
controversial guest but I'd yet you both
handled yourself quite cordially I would
call it compelling is that fair to say i
think i was that about it so follow me
on instagram david pakman a lot of
behind-the-scenes
action happening there and there is a
picture of me shirtless although it's
probably not what people imagine after
many demands i reposted an old picture
from when i was at the beach and that's
on david pakman i would say the ratio of
people making fun of me for the picture
rather than complementing it was
probably about seventy two thirty which
you know it's actually not that bad I'm
surprised that malpense health magazine
was allowing you to use their cover on
yeah yeah I heard I heard nothing by the
way from any and fitness magazines I
wonder why